Reuel Colt Gridley was born and raised in
Hannibal, Missouri in 1829, and lived there
contemporaneously with Samuel Clemens (aka
Mark Twain), with Clemens claiming Gridley
was a schoolmate of his.
Leaving Missouri for greater adventure out
west as a teenager, Gridley served in the
Mexican War (1846-1848) and later joined the
great California Gold Rush in 1852.
(See: What Sparked the California Gold Rush?)
He soon left mining and experimented with
a few professions, including banking and mail
delivery, before following another mine strike
to Austin, Nevada where he established a general
store.
Easy-going and good-looking, Gridley was successful
as a shopkeeper and popular in town.
In 1864, he ran for mayor of Austin as the
Democratic candidate and struck up a friendly
wager with the Republican candidate, Dr. H.S.
Herrick: whoever lost the race would have
to carry a 50-pound sack of flour for more
than a mile while a marching band played a
tune of the other’s choice.
(If Gridley had won, Dr. Herrick would have
marched to Dixie).
Gridley lost, and so, carrying the 50-pound
flour sack decorated with red, white and blue
ribbons and accompanied by his teenage son
(who was carrying an American flag) and a
marching band, Gridley marched from Austin
to Clinton while the band played John Brown’s
Body.
Attracting a fair bit of attention, a good
crowd had gathered at the saloon where the
two opponents ended the day after the procession
was over.
As neither Mayor Herrick nor Gridley wanted
the flour, it was suggested that they auction
it off and send the proceeds to the U.S. Sanitary
Commission, an organization established by
a New York minister to aid wounded Union soldiers.
Samuel Clemens was also in Nevada at that
time, in the neighboring town of Virginia
City.
As he wrote in 1872’s Roughing It, Nevada’s
residents in the 1860s were flush from the
proceeds of their great silver mines, and
accordingly had more money than they knew
what to do with.
In that environment, the flour sack was auctioned
off with the winning millman bidding $250.
According to Samuel Clemens, when the millman
was asked where he’d like the flour delivered,
he stated, “Nowhere- sell it again!”
Getting into the spirit of things, miner after
miner lined up to bid on it, and each time
it was sold, following the millman’s example,
it was re-donated, such that by the end of
the day, $5,000 (about $75,000 today) had
been collected in Austin.
The story of the flour bag auction spread
and other towns requested that Gridley come,
with Virginia City being the first to send
him a telegram stating, “Fetch along your
flour sack!”
Realizing he was on to something, Gridley
did indeed hit the road.
However, in Virginia City, initially the auction
brought in less than had been seen in Austin.
To rectify this and restore their town’s
pride, a second auction was held.
Clemens noted,
Till late in the night the principal citizens
were at work arranging the morrow’s campaign,
and when they went to bed they had no fears
for the result.
At eleven the next morning a procession of
open carriages, attend by clamorous bands
of music adorned with a moving display of
flags filed along C street and was soon in
danger of blockade by a huzzahing multitude
of citizens…
Gridley stood up and asked who would make
the first bid for the National Sanitary Flour
Sack.
Gen W. said: “The Yellow Jacket silver mining
company offers a thousand dollars, coin!”
After this successful auction, Gridley traveled
to other wealthy mining areas, and then throughout
California (including Sacramento and San Francisco).
Exhausting the West, he traveled east and
continued to sell the flour sack for charity,
ultimately stopping the campaign in St. Louis,
where the flour was used to bake little cakes
that sold for $1 each (the proceeds of which
also went to the Commission).
In the end, the single, 50 lb. bag of flour
raised close to $275,000 (about $4 million
today) in the various auctions it was sold
at.
Sadly, Gridley spent his entire life savings
financing the 15,000 mile charitable campaign.
To make matters worse, shortly after he returned
to Austin, the silver boom ended ultimately
killing his General store.
Suffering from a rheumatic condition, he moved
to Stockton, California where his sister lived
in 1868.
He died two years later
in 1870 at
the age of 41.